what is up everybody it's 414 anime here
for anime Opera and today I will be
breaking down and explaining every Stern
Ritter's power from the bleach Series so
the stern Ritter are all insanely
powerful Quincy and are the biggest and
most powerful force in all of bleach
introduced of course in the Thousand
Year blood War Arc so today I thought
it'd be pretty fun to break down each of
the stern Ritter and their powers and
abilities now if you do enjoy these
bleach videos on the channel and you'd
like to see more you know what to do of
course smash that like button as it
really does help us out with that
YouTube algorithm if you haven't already
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications you can also follow
us on Twitter and Instagram at anime
Oprah and of course now without further
Ado let's jump into It spoilers and all
the stern Ritter are made up of 26 very
powerful Quincy that are all equal or
greater than Captain level power these
Quincy are tasked with the invasion and
complete destruction of the Soul society
and with it the Shinigami now sternrita
is the German word for Star Knights and
the Japanese word for Star-Crossed
Knight Order each of the stern Ritter
underwent a ritual in which they would
drink the blood of yuhar the man who
they serve as pretty much their own God
upon drinking yuha's blood he would
carve a part of his very own soul into
that Quincy in the form of a letter that
will grant that Stoner to their own
unique powers and abilities called a
shrift the letter is a sort of
designation within the alphabet and the
letter corresponds to the Quincy's own
personality deeming what their abilities
will be now if a Stern Ritter were to
die their granted Powers would then be
returned to yuha interestingly there
were two Stern Ritter who were not
granted new powers upon the initial
insole writing ritual these were pernida
and Gerard Valkyrie who already
possessed unique powers of their own and
instead received a shrift in recognition
of their status now the stern Ritter are
a very interesting bunch and what sets
them apart from the Espada is that there
is not any ranking involved within them
they are all created to be a unified
fighting force of course yuha is their
leader and then we've got jogrim who
holds the title of the stern Ritter
Grandmaster who you know acts as yuha's
right-hand man yuhar also has four Stern
Ritter who are appointed as his own
Elite guard called the shoot Starfall
but that's about it when it comes to
rank yuhar wants to keep his Stern
Ritter fighting on the same page you
know as a uniformed and well organized
fighting force there is even a law that
forbids the stern Ritter from fighting
amongst each other on pain of death so
with that breakdown on what the stern
Ritter are let's look into every
sternwriter's Power in alphabet order
so uriu Ishida is first up as the letter
A which stands for anesthesis his power
anethesis which is Japanese for perfect
anti-setup allows uriu to designate any
two Targets that he so chooses and can
completely reverse anything that has
occurred between the two of them for
example if uriu had been severely
injured while fighting an enemy he could
designate both himself and his enemy as
targets and then reverse what had just
happened to him so that he would be
healed and the Damage that he suffered
would then be dished out to his opponent
which is pretty gnarly
ulio's holy weapon is a holy or sacred
bow that is light blue colored and about
the same length as Uriah himself it has
a thinner handle compared to his other
bows and the bow itself splits into a
cross-like shape this bow allows ulio to
fire up holy arrows or sacred
destruction arrows these arrows are like
his normal ones in which he pulls in
reishi from his surrounding area that
manifests into the arrows that he can
fire but these ones are different in
their appearance when using this bow
uriu also has an ability called light
rain where he no longer needs to visibly
collect reishi in preparation for the
attack but instead can unleash a load of
arrows at his Target in an instant
Joe Graham is the stern Ritter
Grandmaster and his designation is the
letter B which stands for the balance
the balance which is Japanese for World
Harmony is somewhat similar to urius in
that jugram can take the misfortune that
happens within his circle of influence
and then disperse that to those that
have experienced Good Fortune themselves
so just like uriu's power if jogren were
to receive bad damage himself he could
then take the damage that he had just
suffered and then inflict those same
wounds onto his Target who was
experiencing Good Fortune themselves
this act balances the scales as their
Good Fortune is mixed with the bad
fortune bringing said balance back into
play now Joe Graham's Spirit weapon is
the friend Shield or sacrifice Shield
through reishi drokum can Manifest this
shield on his left arm that is not only
very strong but also just as sturdy
rather than acting as a normal shield in
which she would imagine to block
incoming attacks from his enemies The
Shield actually absorbs The Misfortune
that jugram would suffer such as the
before mentioned injuries doing this
program avoids most attacks coming at
him directs them to his shield and then
using the balance fires that back at his
opponent jugram is also the only Quincy
other than yuha himself who can impart
his own power into another Quincy he is
also not like the other Quincy in which
he can't naturally absorb reishi from
his surroundings but instead is able to
give reishi to those around him
interestingly jugram also has yuha's
power the Almighty which in Japanese
means all-knowing and all-powerful at
night while yuhar falls asleep the power
of the almighty is jugrams to use but
only while yuha sleeps the power allows
jugram to see into the future but cannot
alter the future just like yuha can
next up is pernida one of yuha's
shootstaffle and also the left hand of
the Soul King whose designation is c for
the compulsory the compulsory is a power
that isn't actually a shrift given to
him by uhub an ability that he had
already possessed here Pineda can shoot
his nerves from its fingers that will
then attach to its opponent's body once
attached penita can control its Target's
body through his own nerves not only can
he control the movements of their body
but he can also tear their body apart in
a mere instant too if he so wished to
Pineda can also use his nerves on
non-living objects and surroundings so
that it can control the shape of them it
used this technique to spawn giant arms
and hands from the ground and buildings
to attack its enemies penina can also
use the compulsory remotely if one of
its fingers had been severed an eye
opens on the knuckle of the finger that
was removed now pineda's Spirit weapon
is a holy or sacred bow that looks like
a traditional bow and arrow that is
wielded between its ring and index
fingers firing the bow with its thumb
with the bow also comes the holy arrows
these arrows are extremely powerful with
just one Arrow wielding the destructive
power to take out an entire Tower
another cool thing is that Pineda
confuse its nerves with the arrows so
that he can hit a Target at greater
distances
Askin is another of yuha's shoot start
full and the stern Ritter with the
designation of D which stands for the
death dealing the death dealing which
means lethal dose is a power where Askin
can calculate the perfect lethal dose
that will cause death on his targets
without fail using any substance he
takes into his own body both raising and
lowering its value as he so chooses and
then inducing that lethal dose into
those around him as an example Askin
needs to consume a lot of whatever it is
that he wants to manipulate into his own
body let's say blood he can then
decrease the lethal dosage of the blood
in his opponent's body making it fatal
to them now he has multiple abilities on
show here which include the power to
heal himself by raising the lethal
dosage Askin also develops an immunity
to substances or energy-based attacks he
is attacked with then there is gift ball
which is basically a small ball of
poison that is potent enough to drop
most enemies upon contact asking can
also fill the gift balls with other
substances such as nitrogen oxygen and
even reishi he also has the gift bad
where he creates a larger circle on the
ground which becomes a dark area of his
influence anyone that steps within that
boundary will be affected as he can
lower that person's resistance to
absolutely anything this causes them to
be poisoned by high amounts of whichever
substance that hiso chooses now his
Spirit weapon is that again of a holy
bow his bow handle is made up of several
small bands that wrap around his wrist
and then spiral into a normal looking
bow the holy arrows that Askin can fire
are pretty long arrows compared to the
normal ones and he can fire two of these
arrows at once not only that but he can
also fire arrows from his index finger
Askin also has a Quincy Vol standing
called hashin which is Japanese for
God's poison tester in this form asking
gains angelic wings but his look like
molecular sequences and has the same
structure around his waist like a belt
his
vanding also enhances the power of his
death dealing directly affecting the
changes in the poisons the point where
asking becomes immune to it and you know
is prevented from harm himself he has
multiple abilities including gift Ball
deluxe which is basically a much larger
version of the gift ball that we had
already talked about poison realm is a
large barrier of light that cannot be
escaped from then there is gift ring
where asking enlarges the bracelet on
his arm and throws it at his opponent
the part of the body that this bracelet
strikes forces the potency of the death
dealing to that exact point which in
many cases causes an instant death
finally asking has also been seen to use
a reishi staff when he is forced to
fight in close combat in this form
bambietta's designation is e for the
explode the explode which is Japanese
for bombing rain is a power in which
bambietta can create explosives or bombs
that she will rain down upon her enemy
these aren't actually bombs made of
reishi themselves but reishi that turn
anything that it comes into contact with
into bombs meaning that her attacks are
ones that cannot be blocked she could
not only target specific enemies but
also large areas causing a huge amount
of destructive damage bambiata can also
generate explosive energy around herself
which looks like that of a very large
sphere now bambias can transform
concentrated reishi into weapons but her
favorite Spirit weapon is that of a racy
sword that looks like that of a
broadsword but meat is Quincy Vol
standing gives her the ability of flight
through giant reishi wings that she can
then fly through the air at high speeds
her Vol standing also enhances the
explode by releasing orbs of reishi from
underneath her Wings by doing this she
can create a large amount of these orbs
which will cover a greater area anything
that comes into contact with these
reishi orbs become bombs that will
explode near instantly
as Knott's designation is the letter f
for the fear his Spirit weapon is that
of several reishi Thorns that float in
close proximity of him these Thorns are
fired at his enemies with great speeds
impaling them in a very very nasty
manner his ability the fear is tied into
these reishy Thorns he wields not only
can these things cause great destructive
power but when used with the fear they
cause the target to feel a limitless
fear themselves when they are struck by
these Thorns now this causes his enemies
to lose all control of themselves and
doubt everything that they are doing
they lose all sense of themselves and
are met with visions of their own
greatest fears in some cases this has
even led to death due to that person's
heart giving out due to the intense
shock that they were going through now
his Vol standing is called tartar Forest
which means fear of God the look of his
Vol standing is absolutely terrifying
and without a doubt one of the best full
standing designs in my own personal
opinion his Vol standing of course
greatly enhances his ability the fear so
rather than being pierced by his Thorns
his opponents simply only need to gaze
upon him to fall into that state of
complete fear and despair that his
ability brings with it he can also
create a large black Dome full of eyes
that ensnares his opponent so that they
will never be able to avoid his gaze
keeping them in a constant state of fear
he can also undergo a fearsome
transformation when his body begins to
absorb the eyes from the fear ability
little Toto's designation is G which
stands for the Glutton the Glutton or
gluttonous when translated is a power
that allows little Toto to consume
anything by manipulating and shifting
her own mouth into an extended form her
mouth transforms into this huge jaw with
many Jagged teeth which she can move to
eat whatever she wishes the downside to
her ability is that it leaves her in a
constant state of hunger now Lil Toto's
Spirit weapon is a holy bow that is very
short and often kept in a hot container
that she wears on her belt her bow has a
heart at its center with the two arms
that Branch out of it the cool thing is
the bow actually resembles that of a
close set of jaws with Jagged teeth that
looks very similar to a bear trap the
Holy Arrow she fires from her bow are of
course Very powerful when she fires an
arrow from her bow the jaw opens when
firing so her Vol standing gifted her
two very tiny wings that look like Teeth
I liked these ones a lot These Wings of
course course give her the ability of
flight at high speeds
baz B is the stone Ritter with the
letter H as his designation which stands
for the heat the Heat or scorching heat
when translated is the ability to
generate flames and launch them at his
opponents by manipulating the reishi in
the air so these frames are that
powerful that they actually managed to
counter the Flames of yamamoto's ryajin
Jacka he has multiple abilities
including burner finger one where he can
shoot out a narrow beam of fire from his
finger burner finger 2 is where baz B
concentrates the power of His Flames
into two of his fingers he then swings
his fingers that creates a large
explosion of destructive damage burner
finger 3 is where he generates heat in
three of his fingers which can melt any
structure he touches with his fingers
and turns that into lava burner finger 4
is a large blade of fire that is created
when he points all of his fingers
forwards he can then slash his opponents
with this fire blade causing large
explosions burning full fingers is a
spiraling cone of flames that is
Unleashed when he generates fire around
all five of his fingertips finally there
is burning stomp which is basically a
large release of heat and fire when he
Stomps his foot on the ground so baz B's
Spirit weapon is that of a crossbow with
the hilt of a handgun shot much like a
Quincy bow the power of his crossbow and
holy arrows is enough to blow a large
hole through a wall now his Vol standing
gives him two wings that are shaped like
two rods with said Wings he can fly at
very high speeds through the air his Vol
standing also greatly enhances his own
speed allowing him to attack his enemies
before they can even have a chance to
react as well as his speed his burner
finger one abilities also enhanced as he
can fire multiple beams of fire in very
short succession
sangdu is the stone Ritter with the
letter i as his designation which stands
for the iron the iron is an ability that
allows him to coat his own body and iron
he can partially cover areas with skin
or cover his entire body if he so wishes
now this iron is incredibly strong and
durable and is able to withstand the
strongest of attacks not only is this
ability an amazing form of Defense but
it can be used offensively too so by
covering himself in Iron he can charge
straight as his enemy delivering a very
strong knockout blow upon contact so his
Spirit weapon are a pair of reishi claws
they each have four extremely strong
curved blades which he wears on his
wrists and he uses a move called snake
claw where he points his arm at his
enemy and places one fist over the other
doing this he shoots energy blasts
straight at his opponent that look like
a snake's head he did also have a vol
standing but we don't have a lot of
information on it other than that it was
strong enough to break him free of the
eyes prison that Captain hitsugai her
trapped him within
Opie is the executive hunting Captain
with the designation of Jay which stands
for the jail the jail allows Opie to
close the gateways between Dimensions
using reishi constructs he can also use
this ability to create reishi cages that
will trap and ensnare his enemies now
once a person is trapped within one of
his reishi cages their presence become
sealed off from the outside and they
can't be detected they can hear the
voices of everyone outside of the cage
but they cannot be heard themselves so
Opie's Spirit weapon is a reishy sword
that looks like that of a military saber
not only that he also has small reishi
daggers using his reishi sword Obi can
fire holy arrows from extensions from
the sword's guard these arrows are
powerful enough to create explosions
upon impact and he can fire up to six
arrows at the same time now his Vol
standing is called biscal which is
Japanese for justice of God in this form
op gains numerous accessories that are
all made from reishi including boots
gauntlets a sword that comes out of his
right hand and of course a pair of
angelic looking Wings his volstanding
gives him the ability of flight enhanced
spiritual awareness enhance speed and
complete reishi dominance allowing him
to absorb large amounts of reishi that
he can then form into a powerful attack
from the tip of his sword Opie also has
an ability called holy slave in which he
can gather reishi by enslaming him he
can take the reishi from spiritual
objects and make it his own and in doing
so even takes on the characteristics and
capabilities of his victims
bg9 is the stern Ritter with the
designation of K though we do not know
what the k stands for nor the power that
he has been given we do know that his
Spirit weapon is a large 10-barreled
minigun that fires out some powerful
blasts we also know he has a vol
standing however we do not know exactly
what it does
wackabrata's designation is the letter L
which stands for the love the love is an
ability that allows him to shoot a
heart-shaped projectile at his opponent
by putting his own hands together in the
shape of a heart anyone that is hit by
this projectile falls in love with him
and become like so obsessed by him that
they will do absolutely anything that he
asks of them which could include things
such as attacking their own allies he
also has a move called love kiss which
works exactly the same where he puts his
hands together in the shape of a heart
and fires a projectile except this
projectile is like that of a normal
attack rather than a mind-controlling
one his Spirit weapon is of course a
holy bow his bow is very small with a
thick handle that you know he will
manifest by pulling it out of his mouth
the arrows are also manifested by him
pulling him out of his mouth as well
which unique let's let's go with let's
go with the word unique there so his Vol
standing is called God's love
he activates his Vol standing by drawing
a heart shape in the air with his hands
and his transformation makes him look
like a very very ugly Cupid abilities in
his volstanding include that of enhanced
durability flight and a technique Called
Love robe where he will manifest a
floating basket with many robes made up
of linked hearts these ropes he then
throws at his opponent and upon stabbing
them they become completely immobilized
Gerard Valkyrie is not only one of
yuha's shootstuffle but also the heart
of the Soul King Gerard is the stern
writer with the designation of M which
stands for the miracle the miracle is an
ability that Gerard already possessed
Pryor becoming a Stern Ritter he himself
has described his power as the power to
create miracles on himself through
thoughts feelings and his own desires
now his ability allows him to swing the
tide in his favor through probability
manipulation if Gerard is in a battle
where the odds are strongly stacked
against him the miracle allows him to
succeed regardless of how bad a
situation he is in he also has a really
crazy ability called damage empowerment
where he can turn any attacks that cause
damage to him including those would be
lethal into his own power be it you know
strength speed and even control over his
own size now when it comes to
manipulating his own size he calls the
power God size and the bigger that he
becomes the more lethal his destructive
Powers with her his final ability is
tied into one of his Spirit weapons
hofnong which is German for the word
hope and Japanese for sword of Hope
hofnung is a black double-edged sword
that's health is in the shape of a V
with a star at its Center so the
Miracle's last power is Hope infusing
what happens here is Gerard manifests
the hope of his enemies into his sword
making it near unbreakable any damage
that the sword takes is reflected and
then dealt back to the attacker his
other Spirit weapon is a holy bow that
is gold in color with two handles he
fires huge holy arrows from his bow
which he refers to as pure torrents of
power now Gerard's Vol standing is
called power of God here he gains a
Norse looking helmet thick patterns on
his arms and golden white angelic wings
in this form he can fire off energy
blasts from the tip sword that are
powerful enough to completely wipe out
entire blocks of cities Gerard also has
a second Vol standing form where his
body is reformed his helmet is now like
that of a medieval Knight and has two
huge spikes on his shoulders
Robert Accutron is the stern Ritter with
the designation of the letter N
unfortunately we do not know what the n
stands for nor the powers that come with
it we do know that Robert's Spirit
weapon is that of a reishi pistol that
looks like a handgun capable of
producing muzzle flashes he can also
fire off holy arrows or bullets I guess
you could say from the barrel of his
pistol they're those small still deliver
a huge amount of destructive power his
Vol standing is called God's step where
he is granted a collection of reishi
accessories including wings that gift
him the power of flight as well as
enhancing his own speed greatly
Driscoll is the stern Ritter with the
letter O as his designation which stands
for the overkill the overkill is an
ability that grants Driscoll an increase
on his own power each time that he kills
an opponent regardless of the opponent
the more he kills the stronger he
becomes now his Spirit weapon is a pair
of Taco bands worn on his hands that he
can shoot holy arrows from his arrows
are different however as they are huge
in size so huge in fact that he throws
his arrows more like that of a javelin
the force of throws are also insanely
incredible so much so that they can take
out a normal Shinigami with complete
ease
meninas is the stern Ritter with the
designation P which stands for the power
her ability isn't that of superhuman
strength her strength and power are so
great that her punches are completely
devastating alongside this meninas can
pick up and throw very large buildings
with complete ease and if she so chooses
she can dramatically increase the size
of her own muscles even more if she
needs more power her spirit weapon is a
bow she also keeps her bow in a small
heart-shaped container on her belt the
arrows that she shoots from her bows all
have heart-shaped tips many NASA's Vol
standing gives her wings that allow her
to fly at Great speeds her wings are
made up of large heart-shaped segments
Berenice is the stone Ritter with the
letter Q as their designation which
stands for the question now we do not
know an awful lot about their powers and
abilities other than the question allows
Bernice to harm their opponents by
objecting their existence or actions
berenice's power does not work however
if they are unable to fully speak and is
also ineffective against those who can't
fully hear them talking
Jerome's designation is the letter R
which stands for the raw the raw allows
Jerome to increase his size even more
than he already is and has a more
ape-like theme about himself in this
form he can drastically increase the
force of his raws which in turn produces
large destructive shock waves that
hurdle towards his opponents this
ability has proven to be a lot more
effective on the lower ranking Soul
Reapers which has mutilated and in some
cases even killed them however the raw
isn't all that effective against the
higher ranking Soul Reapers such as
kimpachi who was you know only
temporarily deafened by the ability
mask demasculine is the stone written
with the letter S as his designation
which stands for the Superstar if
masculine has at least one person
cheering him on he gains a considerable
boost in stamina and strength enough to
take on two Captain leveled Soul Reapers
and send them flying in just a single
strike not only does he gain strength
and stamina but his durability and
regenerative Powers also Skyrocket with
enough cheers his mask changes and he
takes on a more pro wrestler look that
seriously amps up his power he calls
this star power-up masculine can shoot a
star-shaped beam from this mask again a
move he calls star flash star murder
punch is a huge punch that is insanely
powered up when his mask becomes enraged
a black star appears on the back of his
fist which increases the strength of his
punches by up to 10 times releasing
star-shaped energy bursts he is also
called this move the hammer of Justice
star Lariat or one mile of Arts as he
refers to it is another punch that he is
said to have sent his opponent one mile
away when he has received enough cheers
he also has a few other kind of
awesomely named attacks including star
Eagle Kick Star headbutt star rocket
headbutt and star dropkick I gotta I I
appreciate the theme that I like that no
not really a power but masculine always
has James follow him into battle James
is a small bald man who carries a bell
with him James has a huge amount of
respect for masculine and with what we
know of masculine's powers we know that
James is with him to amp up his powers
while in combat finally masculine's Vol
standing gives masculine a huge power up
that is again activated upon receiving
cheers from James like the other Vol
standings masculine gains a pair of
wings that allow him to fly but he also
gains the move star flash Supernova here
masculine flies way up into the sky and
draws a huge pentagram using the reishi
trail from his wings once drawn out he
flies above the pentagram and calls out
the name of this attack which sends a
huge star-shaped energy attack to the
ground which erupts in monstrous
destructive power
Candy's catnip is the stern Ritter with
the letter t as her designation which
stands for the Thunderbolt as the name
suggests candies can create and control
the power of lightning she will often
manipulate and create these lightning
bolts in her hands and then point in the
direction she wants the attack to go she
can also generate powerful lightning
attacks from the sky to rain down on her
opponent not only can she use lightning
for attacking but she can also use it
for evasion as she can turn her own body
into lightning itself to dodge incoming
attacks so her spirit weapon is that of
a bow with a heart shape at its Center
she can fire powerful holy arrows from
her bow that have lightning Jagged edges
and if she so chooses she can also fire
blasts of electricity from the bow too
Candice's Vol standing is of course
electricity based her wings are six
lightning bolts sprouting from her back
which allow her to fly through the air
she also gains lightning swords but
these swords are actually the same
lightning bolts on her back she
literally just pulls them off her back
and can wield one in each hand these
swords are great for close combat but
she can also turn them into javelins by
throwing them so she is just as
effective at long range combat Candice
also has electrical destruction
punishment which is where she summons a
huge column of electrical energy around
her that she will then concentrate
around her arm and throw at her opponent
letter of designation is you which
stands for the underbelly the underbelly
also known as defenseless is an ability
that allows him to analyze the ryatsu of
a specific Target for an amount of time
let's say here he can determine that
person's Spirit power distribution and
will imprint his letter on his Target in
a grid that he can pinpoint holes in and
Target their ryatsu and then attack them
causing them to be rendered unconscious
or paralyze them the power of this
ability is of course all dependent on
how much time he has spent analyzing
that Target's real soon the more time he
has the stronger his ability
Grammy is the stone Ritter with the
letter v as his designation which stands
for the Visionary the Visionary also
known as dreamer is an ability where
Grammy can turn fantasy into reality for
example if he believes that his body is
more sturdy than steel then his body's
defense is drastically increased a
really awesome way of using this ability
is if he were to suffer any wounds if he
imagines that the wounds have been
healed then that becomes reality and his
wounds are healed it's crazy not only
can he affect his own body but he can
imagine things such as lava stone
pillars water
Etc you know all these elements to
attack his enemy and these elements will
manifest he can also summon forth
weapons and even change the battlefield
to his liking now Grammy Grace's power
is life creation Grammy can create life
with his imagination he used it on
himself to create clones boosting the
power of his own imagination allowing
him to create stronger objects including
a huge huge meteorite now there are of
course downsides and downsides to his
awesome power include things such as his
own concentration if his attack his
attention shifts from his Target then
they could potentially return to their
original state also his imagination can
betray him if he is not careful he could
accidentally imagine bad things
happening to himself which of course
will become reality
neon Soul's designation is the letter W
which stands for the wind the wind which
is also known as twist and turns is an
ability that allows him to deflect
attacks away from the targets of his
choosing this ability however only
allows him to redirect the attacks and
not count them but nonetheless is still
a very impressive ability that has
caused swords to just bend away from
their intended targets the wind can also
be used offensively too but can be very
nasty now by moving his fingers towards
his opponent he can cause the wind to
cut his desired Target clean in half by
making each opposing end Bend away from
itself
Lily Barrow is the leader of yuha's
shootstaffle and has the letter X as his
designation which stands for the x-axis
the x-axis which is also Japanese for
piercing everything is an ability that
allows his rifle to you know pass
through absolutely everything within its
line of sight his attacks cannot be
blocked by any defense Lily can also use
the full power of the x-axis when both
of his eyes are open now Lily himself
said that the full potential of his
power allows even his own body to pass
through enemy attacks and he actually
keeps his left eye closed as he believes
his power is unfair on his opponents
talk about confidence in yourself right
so it comes as no surprise that his
Spirit weapon is that of a rifle going
off what we had discussed with the
x-axis his rifle is huge in its
appearance and fires holy arrows or
bullets in this case that are strong
enough to completely Wipe Out the cities
surrounding the soul King palace with
just a single shot these bullets are all
so powerful due to the highly compressed
ratio that they are made of so Lily's
Vol standing is called Divine judgment
and the appearance of this thing is
insane it's most noticeable standout
thing are the cute feathery White reishi
Wings These Wings give you know him the
ability of both flight and teleportation
in his Vol standing the x-axis ability
is also enhanced as he can shoot beams
of energy from the holes in his wings
are his Target now if he fires from the
six holes at the same time the
destructive power is enough to wipe out
entire cities in this form he is pretty
much Untouchable Lily also has a second
form in his Vol standing that will
regenerate any lost limbs he suffered
and that's if he was attacked somehow
not only does this form look incredible
but it comes with some gnarlier
abilities including Ray of judgment
which are waves of energy that are fired
from his wrists and forearms he can can
create a large ball of light that erases
all of the nearby shadows and has a move
called Trumpet Of God where Lily can
create a huge trumpet made of reishi
that fires huge energy blasts of
destructive force
Lloyd and Roid are identical twin
brothers who share the designation of Y
which stands for the yourself
the yourself ability allows the brothers
to transform themselves into an exact
physical likeness of another person so
Lloyd's version allows him to copy the
spirit Power and abilities of a person
and roid's version allows him to copy
the memories and personality of the
individual now roid Spirit weapon is a
reishi sword that is exactly like
yuhar's ornate sword due to
impersonating yuha roid can fire holy
arrows just like yuhar from the palm of
his hands these arrows are larger than
normal Quincy arrows though they can
still be fired with extreme force
gazella is the final Stone Ritter in
this video so her letter of designation
is Zed or Z which stands for the zombie
her power is a control-based power in
which anything and anyone that her own
blood is splattered on Falls completely
under her own control so the stronger
the opponent she wants to control the
more of her own blood she has to spill
on that specific Target now those under
her control become corpses and she can
order said corpses to do her bidding the
power of the zombie does not work on
other Quincy however unless that Quincy
has already died and when it comes to
the Quincy though gazelle can actually
summon the corpses of dead Quincy
whenever she pleases and activate their
abilities remotely gazelle also has a
very interesting and kind of creepy
healing technique where she can use the
power of the zombie to heal her comrades
by replacing their wounded flesh or
limbs with that of the deceased so her
spirit weapon is that of a short bow
that has a heart at the same adventure
of it the arms that Branch out of the
bow are skeletal to match her
zombie-like theme she fires powerful
arrows from her bow that have skulls as
their tips
finally gazelle's Vol standing gave her
skeletal reishi wings that gifted her
the ability of flight
and that is it every Stern Ritter's
power and ability from Bleach explained
now I'm a huge fan of the stern Ritter I
just think their designs are really
awesome and I like the uniqueness of
their powers I think his villains common
bleach these guys are seriously
underrated I think they make a very
solid addition to the bleach series
definitely make sure to let us know in
the comment section below who your
favorite Stern Ritter is and which one
you thought looked the best design wise
of course if you enjoyed this video and
you'd like to see more bleach videos on
the channel make sure to let us know by
Smashing that like button it really does
help us out with that YouTube algorithm
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit the notification Bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future anime or pro videos remember
you can also follow us on Twitter and
Instagram at anime or wrong thanks again
and we really can't wait to see you in
the next one till next time my friends
you take care of yourselves